hi
my name is steven and i'm a python
developer
i mostly do a full stack web development
and devops
but as of lately probably the last two
years
i've been doing a lot of data engineer
work as well
and uh currently i'm i'm the senior
software engineer
at analytical where we help support
teams enhance the
their ticket sales and and
enlarge their their donation database
and if you want to find me i make a
bancho everywhere so basically you can
find me as
a bunch on twitter and gitlab github
linkedin
literally everywhere so when i started
working at
uh analytical one of the things that uh
really
shocked me a bit was that
people were talking all the time dude my
my data is bigger than yours right uh
i found this funny because everybody was
talking about big data and how big the
data was and so on and so forth
so i started digging a bit and uh really
looking at what
what really was uh big data right this
is kind of an academic
definition that i found online but i
like it quite a lot so it says
big data high volume high velocity and
or
high variety information assets that
require new forms of processing
to enable enhanced decision making in
size discovery
and processing optimization right this
is a definition like any other
but if we if we dig a bit deeper on on
on the definition
basically we we understand that is uh
big data is not mainly about
the size of the data but it's about
these uh
what what is called sometimes the three
v's right
so it's about volume so the amount of
data you actually have how many
gigabytes how many terabytes you have
it's about the velocity this is the
speed of the data coming into your
system and coming out of your system
and it's also the variety of your data
right so the range of types and sources
that you are reading
for your for your system
uh reading or looking at these
three points uh chances are that you
don't
your data is not big after all right and
and that's not a thing
so don't worry stay with me so
there are a few problems that are in my
humble opinion there are a few problems
uh with big data solutions right so
first for and foremost is that they are
expensive
they need a specialized profile so
finding somebody to work there is not
only
difficult but it's also expensive again
and there are some commercial solutions
out there
either free or like open source or
commercial software that you have to pay
for but all of them they tend to tie you
in and it's very difficult to move from
one to the other
or change if you don't like them so if
you see what i'm going is basically that
not working with big data is is a good
thing or in my
opinion it is it's not a bad thing
actually
i kept on digging on this uh size of of
the data and
i found this interesting website
where they they define small big data
right
and they have this manifesto there you
can check the url is quite quite
interesting
one thing that resonates with me is
basically the second point there that
says that unless you're google or
in this case facebook amazon or one of
these
one of those big guys in the interplay
uh chances are that your data is not
that big in the end right
and and again that's that's good
so for me small big data is something
that usually fits in your computer
so usually or chances are that you're
going to have a
laptop with 16 gigs of ram 32 gigs of
rams perhaps if you're lucky
and then you're going to have also an
ssdisc with
200 and 200 something gigs 500 something
gigs or even more
but if you want to replicate that in the
cloud it might be expensive
right and for these
sets of data that are not big data
big data solutions might might be slower
in the end right so
um most of the cases you're gonna
spread your data around different nodes
in this big data solution and then
you're gonna
compute in these nodes and then you're
gonna gather in a main
uh know that the results and so on and
so forth so you can remind that the
network latency is a big player there
right
so i i think this uh small big data is
something interesting and something that
we should be
looking more into the data engineering
world and that's why i decided to make
this store actually
so in order to to follow the
talk so basically you need to be
familiar with python
that's everything you need we're going
to run all the examples in python
3 8.1 in case you want to replicate it
on on
on your installation but anything about
36
should be enough uh if you don't know
how to install python
there are many many tools home rule i am
from whatnot
and there is this nice article in real
python.com
that you can take a look and and it will
help you install python in your machine
no matter what operating system
all the code examples that i'm going to
show you today can be found on my github
account in this this url and
yeah i'm not going to talk about editors
anyone can can choose their own i'm just
personally i'm using emacs
so the objectives of this of this stock
so we want to enhance memory consumption
and speed
for uh primarily for our etl pipelines
uh usually speed and memory consumption
they can uh together
so less for example less garbage
collection
events is more speed less memory
less vagination means more speed less
memory as well
so they go hand by hum
and then readability is as much
important as a speed load term
so you have an improvement of one
percent or if i find an improvement that
is one percent
only but the code is is much more
difficult to read i will not
put that into production because i know
that future me is not going to
understand what i did i'm going to spend
more time in the end
we're going to try to avoid
anti-patterns as much as possible
and this relates to the to the previous
point
um then before i would suggest that
before
making something more efficient we make
it work we find the bottlenecks and we
make those bottlenecks more efficient
and we won't cover uh garbage collection
or see memory allocation or all these
details even though i would love to but
we just have
half an hour right
so python already offers us as a
language offers us a lot of
freebies things that we can use without
actually installing any any library so
the first one that i'm going to talk to
you about is not actually
uh some functionality of the language
but it's also it's it's more of a
pattern
that everybody uses uh with with python
right so it's
this asks for forgiveness right so most
of the times this is lower to actually
check something than try to do it
when i say most of the times is usually
the most common case
right because you need to be aware that
handling exception is more expensive
than actually
a defense block and let me demonstrate
that with an example
so we have two classes a and b a has an
attribute
a and b has energy with b and then we
have two functions that
they do something with the attribute a
so the first one checks if the object
has the attribute a and the second one
does assume that the the object has the
attribute and if it doesn't raise an
exception and
catches the exception right at the
bottom of the slide you can see
the the the results of uh running this
overall list i think it was a million
objects
in the first cases the list is is made
up out of mostly a's
in which case it is much faster to do
something without asking so hunter
interception
the price of handheld intension is is uh
is much smaller compared to actually
asking every time if the object has the
attribute a
and bear in mind that the the fact that
we are asking for one attribute
at the time that this this is that we
expand on that it
grows with the number of attributes
right now you need to ask for 10
different things
they will be much higher but on the
other hand if the list is made out of
b's mostly is much faster to actually
check
if the object has the attribute a before
actually doing something
and this is uh something that you need
to be aware of when you are
doing this these type of patterns when
you're iterating over a list in this
example is it's quite simple
to see that but sometimes it can get
very very difficult but improvements are
are big if you look at the other numbers
here
so the next the next thing that
python offers us is something that is
called iterator generator and generator
expressions
these three things they try to
to maintain new memory what is really
necessary at a given moment in time
so basically uh if you have a list and
you want to iterate over it
it will maintain only one object of the
list instead of the entire list in
memory
so imagine that you have your etl right
so you're going to have your extract
function your transform function and
your load function so here i have two
two examples two dummy examples for the
for the extract and transform transform
functions
so this track basically gives a random
number between
uh minus a thousand and a thousand for
one million times right
and this is already a generator which
means that it doesn't maintain
a million numbers in memory at a given
time the transfer function is the
the fees vast algorithm right so uh you
can read through the logic but it's
basically
if the number is divided by ah if is
divisible by five then it returns
uh bias if it individual by three v fees
and if is uh by three and five it
returns uh fees bus
and if nothing of that uh applies then
it returns the the
still representation of that map okay
now if we run that using normal lists
so you see that from the generator that
i showed you before i'm creating an
actual list that contains a million
objects
and then we transform that and create
another list in that case we use 75
megs of ram and it takes 1.29 seconds
which is kind of a lot
and this is something that we want to
avoid so the second example
in on the left is basically taking
advantage of the
generator and it only maintains in
memory
one object from the generator and
entirely transformed list
in this case if you look at the at the
right now and you see the
the results the amount of memory is
almost reduced by half the time is a bit
less but it is not significant in this
case
the last example is an interesting one
in this case we we
create a generator expression and
the generator expression by itself it
doesn't consume memory because nothing
is happening there
until you call next you call next and
one of the
then extract is called it yields
one of the integers transform is called
it runs feasibles on this integer
and gives you the result back so in this
case we are going to have only one
object in memory which is 0.01 max
the the amount of time here is not
significant because i have to be honest
with you i'm cheating a bit
because in this case i'm just processing
one object right but imagine that you
would
send the process data somewhere
one by one in the above examples you
will have to iterate over the list and
send it right so here you could
start sending it from the beginning
which is it is
it is kind of interesting especially if
you want to use the next
next technique that you can that python
is offering you that i'm going to show
you
which are the dreaded multi-processing
multi-threading and async io right
so unfortunately python is single thread
which means that most of
most of the setups
the the system is going to be under use
so you have a
machine with multiple cores and so on
only one of them is going to be used
uh but parallelism can lead to horrible
headaches uh believe me
uh like like like used like we used to
say been there done that right
so this is the the guild that you need
to deal with there are the race
conditions that you
are not gonna like there are the
deadlocks that you are gonna have even
like less and there are more other or
more or any
there are a lot of other things that uh
can happen with threats
but i have to say that if you use them
with caution
they can lead to big improvement right
so especially if you uh if you are
reading from a source
that is slow or you're reading from a
foreign disk
or something like that you can you can
take you can take advantage of things
like a sync io
so imagine in the previous example where
we have the the transform
that our transform uh is uh slightly
slower because it needs to do some sort
of
reading from somewhere i don't know
so i'm uh so the the first example is a
sync function
that is basically waiting for the i o to
happen
and the second one is a normal function
that is uh
actively waiting for the uh i o to
happen right
so here you see that the the speed
improvements are really really
huge in this case this is a toy example
but imagine
in your etl what will happen
if you are waiting for uh i don't know
waiting for
something to come from from a disk and
while you're doing that
you can do something else which is
basically what i think i allows you to
and same goes for multi-processing and
multi-threading
for me those are the three main themes
that python
has that can help you enhance your small
big data pipelines there are other
things that you can use
like uh or you can take profit off like
for example the speed of
sf streams is much higher than the speed
of formatted strings
uh when you you need to check for types
uh you should use instance off instead
of type because this
is as well faster there are other
smaller things and
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave on the
on the github page some some links to
some interesting blog articles where you
can read uh we'll read about all that
um now moving on we're gonna talk about
what i'd like to call the useless aspect
so those are
libraries that you will find most likely
in every other etl pipeline
that will help you write a better and
more efficient
code so typically what you have is
i would say in 90 of the cases numpy
and pandas they are both implemented in
c
and and they are both
implement vectorized operations which
allows them
to do really to to get really high speed
on certain operations and and be really
efficient in terms of memory as well
but as i said there are other libraries
that can help you write better
more efficient etl pipelines so let's
let's check out a few of them
so the first one is a bit of a
controversy here so it's a sql algorithm
so it's an object relational mapper or
an orm
which basically allows you to map python
objects
into database objects or database tables
right
as everything has pros and cons so for
me the main
the first pro is basically that is is
python and not sql not everybody is
is an sql pro and i think this is a good
thing
it's a db agnostic so it's tomorrow you
have to migrate databases you will help
you with that
many queries will perform better because
as i said i'm not an sql
expert so this will help me with that it
will prevent a sql injection
which is a really good thing
and then there are some advanced
features that you actually don't need to
care about that much
though it will handle a connection pool
for you it will help you with the
migrations if you have polymorphism in
your data it will
will also help you with that and and
more
and it also has a few cons the the
biggest one is speed so it's going to be
slower
period but that's not necessarily a bad
thing as i said before readability for
me is more important that
speed uh
it also has a small overhead in the
initial configuration so you need to set
up your connection you need to
be familiar with the with the library
itself the api and so on you need to set
up your basis for the models and so on
so it has a little overhead and
indeed some some queries might perform
worse if you are a
sql guru you might write a really better
performing
queries that being said sql kim allows
you to
run raw sql if you are
so inclined to so let me show you an
example of
sql work sql can be working so we have
the typical
customer with an id and a name uh i
i said that for for this example i'm
using a million customers and then
first thing that i'm trying to do is
basically at the bottom you'll see this
is
saving them with a plain sql to an
sqlite
database in my machine and this do 1.7
seconds so it's really fast it's sql we
know it's fast
then using the the object that i have at
the beginning i'm using the orm
typical urm flow where we create an
object and do a session and commit the
session
it takes 42 seconds to do the same thing
so it's
way more than uh plain
sql right but in the in the last line of
the
of the at the bottom we see that the isq
alchemy has
what they call the bulk operation so
they have bulk insert and bulk update
when you do this this operation you
reduce the time quite significantly
compared to basic orm
flow in this case it's 5.9 seconds
which is more than plain sql
but again i i think in this case we is a
trade-off that we can make
and another thing that is important here
that is if you if you assign
you can assign primary keys for example
the inserts and the updates well you
need to assign for the update so the
inserts
will be much faster in the end and that
is also important because you can
do uh for this uh if you see here i'm
you i'm doing it in chunks of of ten
thousand
so one thing you could do is you can
send
these chunks this insert chunks to
to a thread source i'm not saying a
synchro because i think i don't think
sql algorithm is compatible with a
syncaio
but you could create a spawner thread
let it run there and continue processing
your data and save another terms house
and so on and so forth
the next library that i'm going to show
you today is
is called number and it's a just-in-time
compiler a jit compiler
so what it does is basically it parses
your
python code and then it transforms that
into a
compile code that is much faster than
that to interpret
than python right the main pro that i
have for
for number is that it's really easy to
use so you just drop the add
g to the collector and your function is
immediately pre-compiled
it has automatic parallelization with
the add vectorized decorator so if you
have a function that is meant to run
over a list but you're doing a for loop
over the list and applying the function
you can say add vectorize and pass the
the
the numpy array for example and it will
it will actually run like that
that connects to the next uh pro which
is the
the support for numpy it has really good
support for number and if you are so
inclined to it has gpu support as well
it has a downside like everything so
it's really really really difficult to
debug so you find
if you find an error is if it's a
bit difficult to pinpoint where the
error is happening and why it's
happening
there is no way to interact with with
python and his module in the non-python
mode which
makes sense but again it's there and it
has limited support for classes but if
you have a
a use case where you do a lot of
numerical calculations
in your etl you will really benefit from
that
like in this example so say that you
have to you in your etl you need to
calculate the distance between two
points
right so this is the function that
calculates distance without number it
takes 2.5 seconds and with numbers
takes stereo 0.3 seconds if you look at
in github
at the code the difference between the
two functions is the g decorator
that's it easy
the last library is dusk we love dascat
for analytical
so it's basically a general purpose
parallel programming solution
that scales familiar analytic tools like
numpy pandas and cycler
so i said that we loved us basically
because they don't try to reinvent the
wheel
so there is a really established api
like the pandas api and they basically
implemented that in a parallel way
so if you look at the examples here at
the bottom of the slide basically the
first three lines are importing a csv
are
sorry reading a csv file and calculating
the mean on the distance
and the the last three lines are doing
exactly the same
but with dusk i think the only
difference the only two differences are
the import statement
and the dot compute at the end so my
colleagues on the
on the machine learning side they they
love this because they can scale
their uh their pipelines
much better than what they could be
doing before
with just pandas on a single machine
or even signal threat we use dusk
for many things but the one that was
kind of our suspect's
story was the find the customer
duplicates and merge them
so what we do here is basically we
extract the data we connect to our
to our external sources and we extract
all the customer account information
from there
and we do that in a daily basis we we
save that
to temporary files uh
transform already into our schema and
then
we basically merge this new data with
the the data that we already have in our
system
and then finally we basically extract
from all the customer information the
new one the old we extract the
matching information and we group using
that much information so most of the
times email will be used
we group and we apply a function on the
grouping and that's it and then we save
the results
into our finalized data which processed
it and then we go from there
so i said that this is our success story
because basically when when i started
working at analytical we needed a
machine that was 32 weeks
that needed 32 gigs of ram to
accommodate all the
data pipelines and then now we are down
to
a gigs of a machine that has eight gigs
we went from one day for processing the
income data for our
largest client down to three hours and
now we are 30 minutes with all the
improvements that i've been sharing with
you
along the slides and as i said we love
to ask and
one of the reasons that we have a
smaller aws build nowadays
so we processed
all the data already we have in our
system so the next natural step there
is to extract features right and that's
where the feature store comes into place
so what is a feature store and why do i
need a feature store so for me it's like
a data warehouse
but instead of storing your raw data
you're storing
features for machine learning right
i read somewhere that 80 of the data
science work is basically data wrangling
and extracting this feature so it's
really precious work that you
need you want to store somewhere and be
able to replicate it
and in our case many of the fields that
we are calculating are used in
several models so being able to read
them calculate them once and read them
many times it was an important thing for
us
then it since we are using that we've
seen a better collaboration since we're
using a feature store
we've seen a better collaboration
between team members especially
when sharing fields because before
i was calculating i feel this way my
colleague was calculating a different
way and we were getting different
results
now there is only one way standardized
way for all the team
and if you do version it will allow you
to do how to identify
data drift quite easily uh from the
features
and it's something that there are many
companies using that i think one of the
first
was uh uber with michelangelo but this
is a
close solution so you can i don't think
you can use it
there are many other solutions like hop
hops work uh
fists and so on others but all of them
have the same problems and many other
data big data solutions that you need
all these
hive clusters patches part clusters
hadoop and so on so forth which can be
expensive india
so what we did is we we tried to do our
opinionated implementation
and for that we use existing existing
and
inexpensive tools like packet files
task and aws athena
we mostly use it for offline usage
but it shouldn't prevent you from using
it for uh
online usage as well because the amount
of data that he needs to read is not
that big
and there is no public release
unfortunately as yet we are
fine-tuning a few things and roughing
and substituting a few rough edges
but it will come stay tuned for that
so our in our implementation started
with
our idea of the consumer high level api
so the first block of code basically is
how you would calculate all the features
that we start from the customer and the
second block is how
my colleagues at the machine learning
side of of the pipeline
will read the feature from the features
right so you can you get a group
in both cases you get the group and one
you calculate and the second one you get
the features that you want
just close them or just close them and
so on so forth and you can actually
apply filters as well
and this will give you back a dash data
frame
so behind the scenes what is happening
is basically that we have a
set of functions that uh we'll query our
our data warehouse apply some functions
like the instance that i showed you
before
and in this case it's using latin long
it's a bit more complicated
but you get that you get the point and
then
it will it will return a dask data frame
and in order to tell
our feature store what fields is going
to calculate the type and the function
that is going to use we have this
configuration object where we have as i
said
in this case the distance field with the
type float
and then we have a function that likes
like an import string
that is going to tell our feature store
where
to look for the function to calculate
some of the features
once we have the functions and the and
the configuration ready
what we do is basically we iterate over
all these functions
and we create threads
to run the calculations once all the as
the threads they
they are coming back they uh we
basically merge the results
sorry and finally we just save that
this is a big big really big task
data frame and we basically save it to
aws
as a compressed uh packet file
and that was the calculate piece then
when we want to read what we do is the
the second
block here in the slide what we do is
we create an aws athena
table a temporary one we point it to the
uh that to the packet file
and then we query that thing once we are
done querying we destroyed the table
because it costs money so we just need
it for the querying piece
and that's our implementations i think
it's quite simple
and it it actually works for for our use
case
so what we learned through through this
uh journey that we did is that
we are much more efficient now as a team
and we are much more efficient now in
terms of develop deployment resources so
we don't need to calculate
the features every time that we run a
model
if i can give you a
an advice is that you start small
basically you're going to start with us
we started with a python script with a
set of function being called inside
and saving the result to a csd file that
was our our starting point
and then we we grow from there if if you
want to
do it on your own i recommend you start
small uh if you're gonna use aw
something it be
bear in mind that it doesn't like dates
so you will store dates in a
in a form that is not the one that you
expect so if you can avoid the
dates uh do so and
yeah it sounds very sexy when you're at
conference and you say no no we use a
feature story it's really a
sexy topic nowadays
so now we've seen our
etl pipeline how we calculate our
features
and now let's see how we run this in
production right
so the glue that puts everything
together is airflow
and in my hyper in my humble opinion we
were using airflow wrongly
for small big data etls and
most of us are i'm going to explain why
so most of us we're
we're using salary to to to run the
tasks
but that can lead to a scenario where
you have one task one worker because the
the amount of memory that this task
requires is
is that big that it doesn't allow
anything else to run on that worker
so you will need many many workers and
the size of your worker
it needs to be as big as the biggest
task you have right
so you have one task that needs eight
gigs and on the tax that needs 32 you
probably need
a worker that needs has 32 weeks
so what we what we did is basically we
are running
nowadays we are running airflow on ecs
and we are still using celery
but in our case we use also the ecs
operator to start a new container
for every single task on dedicated
resources
so what we did is that by doing so our
our salary
machine now is is much smaller and we
allow for
higher concurrency right so we can have
i think each of our workers is doing
uh 10 tasks in parallel lines is not the
smallest machine in aws but is the next
one the costs of actually doing this
this concurrency
are smaller because as i said you can
fine-tune the resources that you need
for each of the tasks
depending on the size of the other task
right so you have a clip you have a
client with
10 million customers and another client
with 100 000 customers the size of the
machines
can be different depending on on that
and
another good thing about about this
approach is that basically there is no
client specific code
deployed with airflow and each client is
deployed independently
this leads to faster deployments and
it can help you with this dependency
help when you have a library that you
use in one client and for whatever
reason you use the same library another
client but a different version
if you were to put everything together
in your salary workers
it will basically not work because you
need the same library with two different
versions
this concludes my talk so if i can give
you four
things that you should take home out of
my talk they are basically
that a small big data is better than big
data
i do believe that i'm not gonna brag
ever about
how big my data is because i know uh
deep inside me that i'm gonna have an
easier
work down the road than anyone that has
uh really big data
um i i would say that uh whenever your
colleagues are
extracting features from your data
please store them somewhere because they
are really pretty
precious work what you are what they are
doing and
um it will it will help everyone down
the road as well
there are many tools and libraries that
will help you
be more efficient and write more
efficient code and eventually spend
less money on on on cloud solutions so
i think you should convince your uh
manager somehow to give you
two days a week or something to explore
things like number or task and how they
can
can help you in your in your daily
operations
you should mention something about roi
or things like that it will it will
really resonate with them
and uh docker is key
in all that uh being able to uh
replicate experiments being able to
run isolate isolated
environment and so on and so forth i
think it's really important especially
if you if you decide to to use airflow
the way that we are
used you cannot attend the
q a session that we that will be uh in
place uh sometime
um i'll be happy to to answer them if
you uh if you ping me on on the github
repository in the form of an issue or
you can shoot me an email just
feel free to do it i'm being told that
i'm a nice guy so
again thanks and have a good one
you